j'en parle avec joanie fontaine
économiste principal chez jls bonjour
madame fontaine
bonjour quand même un peu étonnant on
est en pleine pandémie on pourrait
penser qu'il y une certaine prudence
ralentissement mais au contraire on est
en train de battre des records
oui en fait dans le marché mais bien
présentement on assiste à un effet de
rattrapage de donc tant les deux
derniers mois ont vu des hausses de
ventes par rapport à l'année dernière
mais on a eu des baisses forclaz par le
passé donc son regard la période de mars
à juillet on est encore avec des ventes
moins nombreux cette année
quelle année dernière la période
correspondante exactement à lhassa
pourtant à dire effectivement mais aussi
vous l'avez dit que pendant quoi combien
de semaines ou combien de mois a été
complètement arrêté
le marché immobilier avril mais on avait
vraiment le des baisses de ventes
extreme longtemps de moins 60 70 pour ça
ne fait plus vraiment visiter les
propriétés dont qu'elle ait pu être
tellement de ventes sur le marché
ouais donc effectivement il y avait du
rattrapage à faire et on est toujours
fou le dire dans un marché de vendeurs
oui en fait on se retrouve dans un
marché de wanda malgré des ventes sur
toute la période moins importante parce
que les nouvelles inscriptions
malgré une reprise en juillet on a un
peu plus d'offres qui s'en vient un nom
peu repris aussi fortement levée de
fortes baisses
et finalement ya plus d'offre sur le
marché de mars à juillet on ait eu 23 %
- de nouvelles inscriptions de 1000
jeunes qu'on en avait à 2019 dans tout
c'est trop flou qui n'est pas au
rendez-vous fait qu'il ya une pression
là etc c'est vraiment le marché vraiment
l' avantage des dépendances oui cette
espèce de déséquilibre convoi entre
l'offre et la demande est ce que vous
pensez que ça va continuer lors des
prochains mois ça pourrait perdurer
encore un peu par contre on s'attend à
ce qu'à l'automne ou même le au début de
l'hiver y ait un changement puisque les
allégements hypothèque avons terminé les
gens mon mollet spéciaux 6 terminé donc
et des gens qui ne rompait pas retrouver
leur emploi qui vont devoir vendre on
risque d'avoir des reprises de propriété
par les actions financières
on en a à peu près polluent depuis le
début de la pandémie
étendant les allègements et là on risque
de revoir ses propriétés sur le marché
donc ça pourrait venir changer
l'équilibré alors elle voulait me dit
marché de vendeurs de fortes hausses de
prix sur un an je regardais dans la
région montréalaise le matin pour les
unifamiliales cet avion une hausse de 70
mille dollars sur annales oui il ya deux
phénomènes qui explique cela
premièrement une partie de la hausse qui
vient d'avant la pandémie donc on parle
sur un an donc les premiers mois avant
la pandémie on avait quand même marché
qui était très actif puis le ca continue
d'augmenter étant donné l'offre qui est
très bas donc il ya beaucoup de
compétition pour les unités qui sont sur
le marché
parce que finalement il n'y a pas
d'unité sur le marché donc même si on
n'a pas une demande c'est aussi forte
étant donnée la pandémie mais on a quand
même un certain déséquilibre et là on
voit une hausse de prix donc surtout
dans la banlieue plus en parler de la
base dumont pourrait même dire la grande
couronne notamment de montréal ce
phénomène qu'on remarque depuis
plusieurs années est-ce que vous pensez
que de plus en plus on va voir une
espèce d'exode donc à l'extérieur des
villes on voit un gain dans la banlieue
et même plus loin jusqu'à 1h30 de
montréal on a un certain engouement dû
au télétravail en fait l'aspect
télétravail 1 permet aux gens de dire je
vais m'éloigner tout en gardant une
distance raisonnable avec le bureau
d'annoncer si je travaille trois quatre
jours à domicile une ''journée autres au
travail et je peux m'éloigner me
permettent une maison plus grande pour
un prix qui est moindre qu'en ville donc
on voit un certain intérêt va falloir ça
va rester mais si le télétravail reste
un peu on s'attend à ce qu'un certain
équilibrage entre le centre-ville et les
banlieues puis clusaz éloignés bon la
pandémie on ne sait pas combien de temps
ça va durer
on sait même pas son aura l'accent est
ce que vous entrevoyez une baisse des
ventes alors vous m'avez parlé peut-être
à l'automne qu'on risque d'avoir un
changement de chez moi mais c'est ça à
l'automne début de l'hiver on risque
d'avoir un changement parce que on
aurait pu cet effet rattrapage de
l'effet rattrapage vovos terminer un
certain point donc c'est à ce moment là
qu'on risque de voir davantage l'impact
de la pandémie et qu'on pourrait voir
plus le des reculs de vendée prick
listings un petit peu plus encore le ça
va dépendre grandement des régions
entente on parlait le des secteurs qui
avaient pu favoriser les secteurs plus
défavorisés par rapport à la pandémie
l'équipe de propriété aussi que près +
avantages
par rapport à d'autres donc c'est
difficile de faire un constat général
mais oui c'est là qu'on va plus voir les
effets de la crise économique finalement
que la pandémie écrit on est peut-être
un jour également sur le marché
immobilier dans la région de québec
on voit également donc une hausse de 43%
des ventes alors c'est solide ça aussi
la wii on a une belle reprise à québec
un peu le même effet rattrapage conte à
montréal québec partait avec un marché
moins dynamique que montréal mais quand
même là on voit une bonne reprise ce qui
est intéressant pour ce marché là qu'ils
connaissaient pas des fortes hausses
dont qui partait avec un équilibre
différent de celui de montréal donc un
peu moins de jeu cela demande des ça
mais on voit une belle remontée donc en
sensuelles c'est intéressant pour les
marchés québec aurait peut-être aussi
sur toronto en hausse de 30% sur un an
et un prix moyen
encore une fois on regarde ça qu'on
allait les yeux tout écartillé qui
dépassent le million donc pour une
unifamiliale s'est encore là fier malgré
les mesures qu'on a mis en place et
encore une option un effet de rattrapage
tout comme nous puis encore des des
bonnes hausses de prix mais c'est quand
même rien à voir ce qu'il y avait il ya
quelques années le y ait quelques années
des hausses de prix ça fait excéder les
30 % long et à des chefs un petit peu
plus raisonnables mais ça reste un
marché dit glover et eux aussi ont
l'effet rattrapage finalement alors ça
suit ou lors des prochains mois jo annie
fontaine merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous merci